now remember that line by the
existentialist philosopher Alfred camp
who say life should be lived to the
point of Tears and of course is
referring not to unbearable suffering I
think but rather to aesthetic for
revenge I see when you're moved by
something so beautiful that there's
almost a cognitive dissonance between
what you're beholding and what you know
the average to be right Alan ipython
famously wrote that the reason Beauty
can make us sad is because what idiots
that is the exception is because what it
hints at is the I deal
think about it the term of course is
aesthetic arrest when you witness an
architectural form a painting a
landscape a spectrum of colors that
burns itself on your iris you are
arrested your cognitive apparatus is we
held in aesthetic arrest the mythologist
Joseph Campbell wrote about there's even
a syndrome that can happen in these
moments people can be so overwhelmed
transy curated by beauty that they can
have an actual physiological effects
like heart palpitations they could even
lose consciousness we call this Stendhal
syndrome when religious pilgrims visit
the Holy Land like Jerusalem they stand
in front of the synagogue church or
mosque and before they know it they're
on the floor imagine walking into the
Sistine Chapel and looking up at that
ceiling beauty is an altered state of
consciousness beauty is an extraordinary
moment of poetry and grace Beauty cracks
us open and his Leonard Cohen
it is through our cracks that the light
gets Gavin
[Music]
so are we all addicted to beauty beauty
provide a drug like hi do anesthetics
matter
I remember watching Jordan Peterson
talking about why you need art in your
life and he cited people in a museum
looking at the Renaissance portraitures
and gawking in astonishment and
billion-dollar art collections and he
asked himself what are they doing why
does that bring the cost of billion
dollars why are people standing in front
of it they don't know what that means we
stand in astonishment dumbstruck in
wonder when we gaze upon art because the
transcendent he says shines through the
Matis you feel the same thing when you
walk into a Gothic cathedral even the AC
atheists among us are held captive by
the light coming in through the stained
glass which is like light going through
trees Beauty arrests because it points
to something beyond the everyday beauty
arrests because it hints at a realm of
the sacred Beauty arrests because it
awakens the religious impulse in us
Beauty can shake us out of our jaded
this
there can be no cynicism in response to
be overwhelmed by the beautifu can't
function matter
[Music]
and so surround yourself with beauty
listen to beautiful music soundscape
your world curate your environment
choose diligently the people you share
time with as McKenna said you become
what you behold introduce some art and
beauty into your life it'll seep into
your pores it'll change what lies within
it'll transform the deepest part of you
[Music]
let the music make you cry
gaze upon the faded sunset Weidman
before the sadness
[Music]
let it take over
why do we cry when we see something
beautiful because of the cognitive
dissonance that needs to be resolved the
moment of catharsis is the moment of
absolution it's the moment when the
wrong becomes right
[Music]
to open yourself up to the experience
awaken yourself to our common ecstasy
[Music]
go chase beauty